bienvenidos a esta entrevista exclusiva
de france 24 nos encontramos en la
ciudad de tapachula al sur de méxico y
me acompaña luis rey garcía villagrán él
es el líder de la multitudinaria
caravana que despegó el pasado 6 de
junio desde aquí desde tapachula con
rumbo hacia los eeuu probablemente la
caravana o el ex o más grande en la
historia de este fenómeno migratorio
desde centroamérica hacia norteamérica
un gusto que esté con nosotros luis
bienvenido a este espacio y sobre todo
gracias por acceder porque sabemos que
estos días han sido muy convulsos y han
sido muy cansados también para usted
muchas gracias muchas gracias a todos la
gusto aquí con ustedes bueno luis
empecemos por hablar de los aspectos de
la caravana cómo surgió este movimiento
cómo se conformó esta multitudinaria
caravana hablamos de entre 8.000 a
11.000 personas cuál es el objetivo de
ellos si debido al tapón humano al muro
burocrático impuesto desde hace tres
años por el gobierno de mexico aquí en
la frontera sur donde han convertido a
tapachula en una gran cárcel historia
solamente hay dos opciones para la
población migrante una quedarse
esperando por cuatro cinco seis meses
varados aquí en tapachula en condiciones
totalmente inhóspitas de cualquiera de
cualquier aspecto y la otra es salir
caminando de la forma en que lo hicimos
el día 6 de julio conversando con los
migrantes hay dos lugares donde de
verdad sienten que es muy difícil
avanzar uno es el tapón del darién
frontera entre colombia y panamá una
selva inhóspita donde muchos pierden la
vida pero dicen incluso que ya llegando
a méxico se han encontrado con el tapón
de tapachula pero porque efectivamente
está sucediendo esto que no pasa de
pronto en los otros países de
centroamérica si desde que inició esta
administración la ley el reglamento en
los lineamientos del instituto nacional
de migración vigentes en todo el país
contemplan 22 formas para que un
migrante obtenga un estatus regular
migratorio en el país en tapachula y
únicamente en tapachula se aplican
solamente dos cuáles son esos dos el ser
solicitante de refugio ante la comarca o
el ser reconocido
refugiado ante ante la comarca eso es
una transgresión
directa a cada persona migrante porque
lo que lo hace es detenerse en migración
al ir a las oficinas de la comarca y
esperar una cita esta cita dura entre
dos y tres meses y de ahí obtener una
cita inmigración que que también les
hace permanecer en contra de su voluntad
por dos o tres meses este muro
burocrático fue implementado con aquella
este de aquel discurso de donald trump
que pasó de su muro en los eeuu haya la
frontera con mexico y trajo ese muro
burocrático al suchiate y que ese mismo
muro yo vice no ha llevado hasta la
frontera con honduras a través de
tácticas dilatorias para inhibir la
inmigración en contubernio con todos
estos países inmersos con sus
mandatarios han tratado de detener al
migrante aquí en la frontera sur
haciendo de la frontera azul cárceles
migratorias ciudades cárceles
migratorias como ésta para chula como
estela gutiérrez como es el mismo
wislang como es playa del carmen
villahermosa deteniendo a los migrantes
de pueblo para acá y tratando de hacer
de puebla para arriba otro país
diferente a nosotros nos parece grave y
usted habla de un tema muy importante
que es el de cárceles migratorias aquí
en tapachula hay un centro de reclusión
del migrante que se llama siglo 21 y lo
que hemos conversado con los migrantes
es que allí los han torturado física y
mentalmente qué es lo que está
sucediendo en este lugar cuáles son las
denuncias y qué se va a hacer al
respecto si el instituto nacional de
migración maneja eufemismos para definir
las condiciones en la que cada migrante
está dentro de una cárcel migratoria
ellos dicen están asegurados nadie está
asegurado están privados de su libertad
están privados de su libertad están en
lugares restringidos donde todo el
tiempo hay una tortura física y una
tortura mental debido a que el migrante
detenido lo llaman y le dice quiere
salir de acá tenemos testimonios cientos
de testimonios de esto hay quejas ante
la comisión nacional de derechos humanos
hay queja ante la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos donde
los obligan a firmar los tornos
asistidos es otro eufemismo que utiliza
el instituto porque en realidad son
deportaciones méxico fue el país que más
deporte de américa el año pasado y hasta
los tres primeros meses de este año este
ha roto ese mismo récord quiere decir
que en mexico maneja un doble discurso
sobre el manejo de los migrantes la
cárcel migratoria siglo 21 debe de abrir
sus puertas hay mucha opacidad lo que
pasa dentro se les vende drogas se les
extorsionan a los familiares en eeuu hay
cientos de denuncias hace unos días
cuando partimos nosotros al otro día
ellos se inconformaron adentro de la
estación migratoria y formaron un motín
donde fueron golpeados incluso con
toques eléctricos bueno injustamente la
caravana tenía el propósito de que la
unión hace la fuerza y los que han
podido avanzar ya se encuentran fuera de
tapachula están en huixtla están en
mapastepec como se encuentran de salud
cuáles son las condiciones humanitarias
de los migrantes de esta caravana bueno
desde que salimos la lluvia no dejó de
cesar e incluso estamos viendo
no habíamos tenido estas condiciones en
otros movimientos como esto veníamos
caminando 3000 niños venimos caminando
3000 niños en este en este grupo 5000
familias mujeres embarazadas 126 mujeres
embarazadas mucha población vulnerable
personas en sillas de ruedas
minusválidos mucha gente con problemas
de salud ya de por sí y sin con las
condiciones climáticas la gente se
enfermó se enfermó mucho tuvo
dificultades para caminar la caminata
fue extenuante este 10 12 horas diarias
esté en condiciones adversas poca agua
poca comida deshidratación muchas muchas
cosas pero el ánimo siempre fue muy muy
muy arriba de los compañeros migrantes
de todo de los niños sobre todo luís
terminó la cumbre de las américas y 20
de los países que asistieron firmaron
una declaración en favor de la migración
uno de los pilares es tener un mayor
trato humanitario con los migrantes en
los pasos fronterizos qué opina usted al
respecto bueno en primer lugar nosotros
creemos que hay un doble disco de los
mandatarios de los países involucrados
en esta cumbre de las américas en las
que dicen una cosa y hacen otra cosa
nosotros como defensores de derechos
humanos de los migrantes le decimos que
en primer lugar las mujeres y los niños
migrantes no son la moneda de cambio de
las diferencias políticas económicas o
ideológicas entre los países
involucrados y segunda que la frontera
sur tapachula en específico no es el
patio trasero de los eeuu
hemos visto que tanto en guatemala
méjico los eeuu si se utiliza el
ejército para combatir detener inhibir
la migración de diferentes maneras y de
esta manera combatir en el narcotráfico
el narcotráfico ya estuviera casi
detenido no solamente en eeuu en méxico
y en centroamérica nosotros le decimos
que es esa parte del discurso debería de
hacer práctico al que se aplicarán
políticas públicas más adecuadas para
que la migración no se convierta en un
verdadero problema y se estigmatice a
las mujeres y los niños migrantes como
criminales como transgresores como
invasores de países los migrantes no
somos criminales somos trabajadores
internacionales
señor luís claramente la presión que ha
ejercido la caravana ha funcionado para
que por ejemplo la oficina de
inmigración de aduana de huixtla ya haya
entregado más de siete mil formas
múltiples de emigración para que se
puedan mover libremente los migrantes
sin embargo corren rumores dentro de la
caravana hay desinformación de pronto
noticias falsas de que más adelante
serán los agentes de inmigración o de la
guardia nacional quienes les van a
romper este formato en aras de
nuevamente capturarlos y deportarlos que
tan ciertas esta información lo que se
les entregó es está establecido en el
artículo 174 de la ley de inmigración la
forma migratoria es múltiple este
documento es válido en todo el
territorio nacional pues el instituto es
una dependencia del gobierno federal y
es válido en las 32 entidades
federativas con las que cuenta méxico
pero la corrupción hay que reconocer que
el instituto nacional de inmigración
todas las policías sabía si por haber
son altamente corruptas
en muchos casos en estos tres años de
administración les piden dinero todo el
tiempo a los migrantes le rompen su
tarjeta los regresan a villahermosa los
regresan a tapachula y es por eso uno de
los grandes motivos por los cuales
caminamos para decirles a las
autoridades corruptas incluso al crimen
organizado que por favor por favor no
hagan esto de extorsionar a los
migrantes el documento es válido en todo
el territorio nacional pero no solamente
es la guardia nacional y el instituto
nacional de inmigración son las policías
estatales son las policías municipales
todo el mundo aprovechándose de los
migrantes pidiéndoles dinero sobre todo
en esta parte donde forman ciudad acuña
y piedras negras para llegar ahí golpes
ahí detienen a los autobuses los
extorsionan se suben igual que lo que
platicábamos en ciudad de guatemala para
la llegada a méxico saliendo de san
pedro sula se han aprovechado de los
migrantes están viviendo de la extorsión
a los migrantes al pedirles fuertes
cantidades de dinero a gente que la que
caminó con nosotros son la gente más
pobre de los más pobres de los más
pobres los que están en la cúspide de la
necesidad nos estamos acercando al final
pero no quiero dejar de preguntarle en
todo caso cuáles son las alternativas
que tienen los migrantes para cumplir
ese objetivo de cruzar hacia los estados
unidos solamente para nosotros son dos
tipos de emigrantes sin decir
nacionalidad de los que hay en esta
frontera los migrantes ricos y los
migrantes pobres los migrantes pobres
son los que caminan con nosotros esos
son los que caminan con nosotros los que
no tienen dinero nosotros los que tienen
dinero le pagan aún a un coyote a un
traficante de humanos a un tratante de
personas entre 58 mil y hasta 12 mil
dólares para llegar a la frontera norte
15 tiene incrementados usará sus
bolsillos es el crimen organizado a
través de esta contención de este nudo
humano que permanece en mexico la otra
opción es quedarse en tapachula por 68
meses en condiciones totalmente
inhóspitas para despedirnos quisiera
preguntarle señor luís
porque es el líder de la caravana porque
está detrás de esta ayuda a los
refugiados a los migrantes aquí en el
sur de méxico pues principalmente estoy
tratando de regresar lo que en un
momento la sociedad la providencia hizo
por mí estuve 12 años 5 meses 19 días
prisionero acusado un delito que nunca
cometí y hubo mucha gente no solamente
en méxico sino en el extranjero que me
ayudó a salir y obtener mi libertad y
reconocer que fui acusado injustamente y
lo único que hago es regresar a la
sociedad a los más necesitados a la
gente que está que no lo puede ayudar
nadie a que ellos obtengan a través de
esto que estamos haciendo nosotros
cumplir su sueño americano cumplir sus
metas poder hacer algo para ser mejores
seres humanos señor luís rey garcía
villagrán activista en favor de los
derechos de los refugiados de los
migrantes muchas gracias por haber
estado en francia el cac ya está aquí y
dios te bendiga ya todos los que nos
escuchan a ustedes también muchísimas
gracias por su sintonía y por favor
sigan informando se en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com
y